alain brunet bonjour bonjour votre plus
grosse semaine de l'année que ça
commence les acculant alors on est bien
heureux de sa nou la plus grosse semaine
mais sinon il ya une montée en puissance
puis le début de la semaine prochaine va
tous très très fort là jusqu'au 24 je
brûlais l'année 2015 vous êtes fait
rentrer dedans un peu par un madrier
avec le rapport au billard en disant
vous êtes pas efficace vous dépenser
trop et c'est ça sa teinte et la fin de
l'année ce que vous répondez à sion n'a
pas eu l'occasion à l'époque de faire
une entrevue vos coûts d'exploitation
sont trop élevés ou quoi là nous leur à
part de la commission revient on le
prend comme un outil de réflexion a fait
retentir gouvernement mais quand on
compare des pommes avec des pommes note
clairement on est au niveau de
rentabilité et d'efficacité que je vais
vous donner les bio par exemple alors il
faut il faut c'est sûr qu'il faut tenir
compte du marché ici on vend pas la
bière est en vente privée la boys band
va bien mais quand on met ça coûte et
puis on regarde en avant nous on n'est
pas complaisant
on est des agents de changement on est
toujours en approche d'amélioration
continue qui on travaille là-dessus tout
donner ce que les gens veulent savoir ce
que ça coûte plus cher au québec parce
qu'il ya un monopole par rapport à
l'ontario le monopôle ontarienne le
rapport disait que oui que vous étiez
qui c'était la phrase était manque
d'efficacité elle s annulent nous dit sa
courbe objets et faut travailler là
dessus c'est pas fini nous ce qu'on fait
c'est vraiment travail pour toujours
avancé est encore plus profitable à
notre notre point c'est pesé on n'a rien
à apprendre
au contraire il faut se remettre en
question faut se poser les bonnes
questions est encore plus performant
on parle d'une bonne place mais c'est
pas une loi économique que s'il y avait
un peu de concurrence c'est ce que croit
d'ailleurs le rapport bien vous serez
obligés de gruger dans vos frais
d'administration puis pas augmenté
pour les québécois c'est ça que les gens
se disent non alors si on est efficace
puis on a des balises pour se comparer
puis on s'améliore moi je dis au
contraire comme on est le plus gros
acheteur parmi les plus gros acheteurs
au monde mais on peut en faire
bénéficier les québécois je vous donne
un exemple quand on achète nous le vin
on négocie on négocie beaucoup interne
acheteur important donc on a les prix en
conséquence on à l'offre en conséquence
et quand on distribue sur québec nous on
distribue partout au québec donc leur
fait égal que ce soit à havre saint
pierre ou à montréal c'est les mêmes
produit les mêmes prix le même service
la même compétence
la concurrence ne ferait pas baisser le
prix des bouteilles soit écrit noir sur
blanc dans le rapport le pied il est
beaucoup de gens beaucoup de gens qui
regardent si on fait du manque le marché
des petits détaillants qui achète t on
pas le rapport de force grossistes qu'on
a alors eu à la shop c'est un des coins
porte à la question du produit moi je
pense pas qu'ils auraient d'aussi bons
prix puis ensuite on fait augmenter le
marché alors à ce moment-là la
distribution c'est pareil ils peuvent
pas distribué partout au québec
vous le savez que vous pouvez monter le
prix il ya personne à côté qui peu avant
donc ça marche pas comme ça parce que
maintenant la clientèle compare on
parlait quoi avec tous les outils on
peut comparer les prix avec l'ontario
new york partout dans le monde on
compare maintenant alors cela c'est très
important c'est dans notre réalité
en même temps il ya un choix social
parce que les employés de la saq que les
québécois prennent sv sont davantage
payé qu'un commis d'épicerie par exemple
est un cheval ça c'est un chouette c'est
en fonction de l' expertise nous on a
fait le choix clair on n'est pas les
seuls à face j'ai donné l'exemple de cos
coupe le font la même chose on veut
retenir nos employés on veut les formes
et on veut travailler à long terme en
veille dans l' expertise
on veut pas je sais bien accompagner
at-elle on va être en f1 alors pour ces
choix là
moi je pense que on a nos portes d'agen
convaincu d'autres ça rentre bien dans
le modèle et sa fille travaille
d'ailleurs la libye au fait le même
choix
il peut aussi bien leurs employés les
chiffres qu'on donnait sais que ça va
vous coûter 25 sous par dollars vendus
aux frais d'administration et là vous
avez baissé à 19
mais là il si bio est à 16 sous scellés
les chiffres qui roulait beaucoup
donc il ya encore du gros d'un système
enquête pendant bureau pour nous quand
on compare des pommes avec des pommes
puis on tient compte du marché québécois
pour fait la comparaison avec les idiots
comme vous faites
puis on exclut exemple la bière l'abord
la bière est vendu par le monopole en
partie ce qui est pas le cas du tout ici
alors quand on compare on est au même
niveau on arrive aux mêmes chiffres au
même 16% qui vont perriot et nos
chiffres ni lui son thème je brûlais
souvenait ça l'a bien pourquoi vous avez
laissé le rapport aux bières dire ça
alors si c'était à ce point info quand
je proviens d'entrevue puis pourquoi la
saq et palais sur la place publique alsa
ils ont mal comparé et ça fonctionne pas
enfin nous on ne fournit les chiffres on
aura en eux rendus disponibles cette
base de fellow et puis on a passé notre
message à l'aller nous on n'est pas dans
des boyaux le débat public c'est pas moi
je suis ici pour gérer le commerce c'est
quoi la prochaine étape le prochain
tournant mal gouvernement décidera sur
la concurrence supposée ressources pour
vous qui allez décider de votre point de
vue la prochaine étape importante pour
les accusés c'est ce qu'on fait en ce
moment on est là c'est ce qui inspire on
est aussi dans le numérique à l'heure
nous car la petite carte
et puis on a aussi l à s'impliquer
acheter ramasser en fait ce sport très
content
qu'est ce qu'on veut ce qu'on peut faire
maintenant c'est achetant un an tout en
commander via le web leaf a livré dans
un magasin près de chez soi seul virage
numérique là c'est vraiment la grosse
affaire parce que la clientèle
rendue dès lors vous avez vu cette
caricature là que c'est le prochain
produit vendu potes à l'insa qu il ait
l'ont embauché le gel très bien les
fameuses passes et saucier vous est pas
si elle est passé mais c'est vous la wii
voilà je passe au travers des quêtes
mais j'étais dans lequel hockey vente du
pote bon on en rit mais vendu potes vous
pouvez concevoir ça en fait non on n'est
pas dans ces dossiers là ce moment siens
beaucoup beaucoup d'eau qui vont couler
sous les ponts
d'abord stade au cinéma espace au
général
vous connaissez les circuits comme le
fond de votre page que vous il pouvait
imaginer à ce moment ci ça dépend de la
teneur du projet et au lacet piétonne
veille qu'on fait on si on se positionne
pas ne pas se positionner son
gouvernement à se positionner mission
volume hors d'elle même atteint monsieur
bonnet je vous demande d'avoir des
comptoirs a pas de chez vous fait quoi
si le gouvernement est rendu là on
prendra et on va s'ajuster
moi j'ai pas d'opinion à ce moment ci
parce qu' on est loin du pour lg ça
serait quand même bizarre d'ailleurs les
particuliers avec why are a hier un
étalage de potes à côtés des bordeaux et
16h à imaginer parce qu'on ne sait pas
dans quelles conditions d'avancement
donc on verra à ce moment que brunet je
vous souhaite un bon temps des fêtes
parce que beaucoup de québécois vont
venir dans des saq et je pense qu'on
n'est pas tout on n'est pas conscient
toujours du poids économique de cette
affaire là et merci joyel souhaite à
vous et à tout le monde merci la
prochaine